hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
february 8th 2021 and i am just
smiling ear to ear smiling ear to ear i
can't remember the last time
i was just happy i just
what what a sunday i just had
i got to tell you man i've never been so
wrong in my life
a lot of you guys probably think that
i'm going to gloat i was so wrong
about the balance bike you know i took
my daughter
out to the park and i figured it out
finally you got to like you got to take
them after they kind of
they get bored with it when they're on
like the level what am i talking about
here
todd brady won his seventh [ __ ] super
bowl
wow brady to gronk twice whoa
leonard fournette running that [ __ ]
ball just like i said
just like i [ __ ] said oh
i try to be humble people i can't on
this one i told you [ __ ] since
back in november
how beatable a team like kansas city was
i told you i [ __ ] told you bill
belichick coaches the cleveland browns
they win that [ __ ] game
they just didn't stick with their game
plan to run that's what you do it's what
you do
it's what the [ __ ] i said oh god
damn it i feel good
sorry tom brady seven rings
seven rings he's one behind belichick
now for all you [ __ ] [ __ ]
had a buddy of mine just going oh bill
belichick's probably drink a gasoline
right now bill belichick has eight rings
okay tom brady just passed michael
jordan it's un
[ __ ] believe i've never been i was
rooting for tampa bay
in that game it was like the patriots
were playing that's how much i gave a
[ __ ] i couldn't believe it
i was actually upset with myself and
when they went for it
for that [ __ ] touch when they went
for it on fourth and goal in the second
quarter i
might my family had to leave the room i
was like what are they doing what are
they doing what are they doing they
don't get it
why would you do that
i just realized that's the wahlberg line
when when his mother's tearing down his
posters and boogie nights
don't do it why would you do that stop
it
that's literally i bitched about
them having three points in their back
pocket in a [ __ ] championship game
and not kicking that field goal i
bitched about that until about eight
minutes left in the fourth quarter
that's when i could finally relax
because that's how good kansas city's
offense is
um but i gotta tell you two a [ __ ] t
two a [ __ ] t they did exactly what
the [ __ ] a stand-up comedian said they
were gonna do that's not bad come on
people you gotta give it up okay i'm
gonna
i'm gonna gloat on this one
double tyrique let [ __ ] kelsey beat
you underneath he's gonna get a bunch of
yards but he's not going to get it all
on one [ __ ] play
the native kansas city comes out and
scores quick you don't you don't lose
your composure stick with the [ __ ]
run
wear down their [ __ ] defensive line
you're going to be running downhill
getting first downs chewing up clock
in the second [ __ ] half it's exactly
exactly what the [ __ ] happened
oh oh freckles want some [ __ ] money
on that super bowl
i bet the coin toss heads oh [ __ ] i
missed the gatorade i said blue gatorade
i think i lost on that one
um i didn't go red it just seemed too
obvious both teams had red
you know and i don't i know that
gatorade didn't make
pewter in the blue i always thought
tasted pretty good or the lime i should
have gone with the lemon lime
i don't even know what i mean maybe i
won i have no idea i didn't even look i
was just so
[ __ ] excited in seeing brady the
gronk for two touchdowns and then
antonio brown
who patriots nation still loves
even though he you got that victory
against the dolphins
uh you know in 2019 or whatever
um i don't know every all my pat's
friends that all pats fans are going
[ __ ] nuts we're all so happy for the
guy
so don't believe any of this [ __ ]
[ __ ] i saw in the nfl network or
some crap they were like how do patriots
fans feel
and these [ __ ] [ __ ] already had
their minds made up of how pats fans
felt
so they had to look and sift and sift
until they find six [ __ ]
jerk-offs that will say what they wanted
them to say
you should have seen these pats fans
they look like they went to like [ __ ]
the patriots pro shop they had so much
pats gear on i'm calling [ __ ] on
it's like well it's like if your
girlfriend broke up with you then she
invites you to the wedding
nobody says that nobody said that but
you know they went out and they
the same way anytime back in the day
when they would show a patriots game
they used to [ __ ]
they go down to the beach and they'd
show like a lighthouse like i
can't i can tell you dude
my 27 years i lived in massachusetts the
only lighthouse i ever saw was when i
and i came back four years later and
they built a fake one at gillette
stadium
making us all out to be lobster
fishermen and tying sailor nuts and
eating clam chowder whatever the [ __ ] it
is was you know like everybody in new
york is going hey i'm walking
here i'm holding a hero
you know and everybody in philly all
they do every day is just stand in line
for a steak and cheese it's so [ __ ]
stupid but that's what they do
anyway um i'm all over the map here i am
so
[ __ ] happy for tom brady gronk tampa
the fans of tampa
that was just i mean jesus christ
the amount of brady bashers throughout
the guy's [ __ ] career i've just never
seen anything like
it um
and this is the one i think that he
needed that will just fight it even shut
jim irsay up i think what's what the
[ __ ] are they gonna say now
the guy beat drew brees in new orleans
aaron rodgers and the packers
in [ __ ] lambo
and then he beat the uh the next
greatest quarterback ever uh patrick
mahomes
[ __ ] unbelievable unbelievable
reminds me of when eli and the giants
beat the patriots
undefeated patriots they beat dallas in
dallas they beat some of
the wild card team i think and they beat
somebody else
i think the cowboys in dallas
and then they beat the undefeated page
just as far as undeniable championships
i put it up with those uh
2008 giants and i never thought the 2008
giants got their
due because it wasn't that they won it
was that the patriots lost because they
were undefeated
and i really feel if we had one loss and
went in there
um they would have got the respect they
deserved and god knows eli never did
with the [ __ ] new york media
they used to talk about that guy you
know right to the end of his career like
he never
he never won anything i don't know it's
weird so weird uh
the uh east coast media is uh brutal
it's [ __ ] brutal boston
is just as brutal at least it was when i
was there so
um god damn what a [ __ ] game just to
watch them
executed so [ __ ] perfectly i mean the
whole patreon homes to no touchdowns
no touchdown uh uh passes
i mean he had like a hundred yards in
the first half it was just
textbook textbook textbook textbook
okay so there you go all you young
football fans remember this super bowl
okay i'm not taking anything away from
the chiefs but i'm telling you when you
have an unbelievable offense but only
a decent defense
you are you are beatable and the deeper
you go into the playoffs the more
beatable you are because the better the
team
you play week after week after week
and they finally you know everybody
knows how to beat them they just
the afc just does not have a [ __ ]
team either with experience cleveland is
the [ __ ] team
um with the right coaching and a little
more experience
can match up with the team like that and
as i said i saw the [ __ ]
you just saw tampa bay beat kansas city
you saw the giants beat the undefeated
patriots
in 2008 or whatever the [ __ ] it was 2001
you saw the patriots beat the greatest
show on turf
you saw the dirty birds beat the 15-1
vikings [ __ ] randall cunningham and
randy moss
looking like juggernauts went into their
own building and beat him
all the way back all the way back
running gun bills
giants beat him [ __ ] elway with all
his [ __ ]
receivers giants shut them down
the next year the redskins shut them
down i've just seen it time and time
again i saw the 49ers shut down dan
marino 48
touchdown passes back when that [ __ ]
meant something in 5 000 yards
they came out in 84 and beat him um
i saw the raiders come and beat the
redskins
he's just seen it time and time again a
defense
what's a running game shuts they just
have him sitting on the sidelines like
[ __ ] bernie sanders
at the inauguration um all right i am
done gloating
okay i was so [ __ ] right about that
game
and i got the money in my pocket
tomorrow to prove it i never talk [ __ ]
but here's the balance
which i was trying to do i was trying to
come on this podcast and be humble i
really was
but i was just so [ __ ] excited i mean
the game literally just ended
15 minutes ago um so now let's balance
it out what was i wrong about remember
when i i [ __ ]
was on my period about the [ __ ]
balance bike and i bought my daughter
this bike
thinking i could put training wheels on
it and the [ __ ] [ __ ] who made the
thing
put a bolt on there that you can't get
off unless you you work at their factory
and have their special
wrench or whatever and i'm like who the
[ __ ] are these guys to decide
um that you know i can't put training
wheels on the bike and i gotta tell you
something that um
the way i learned to ride a bike and
everybody in my generation with training
wheels
was uh was really not smart
[Laughter]
[Music]
and i was hanging on to my old ways and
i was one
i was as wrong about that as i was
right about this for once about sports i
i'm wrong a lot um
but i got to tell you so uh at first we
started off on just level ground
and my daughter didn't get it and
thought it was stupid or whatever and
because
you know she flies around on her scooter
so then
um we found this park
um we stayed at a hotel when uh they
were doing the plumbing
and actually got good news about the
plumbing is everything seems to be
working
and they have one last section and they
realize there's a way to go from the
outside of the house
under the house to do it and not have to
dig into my walls or anything
so anyway we were away and there was
this beautiful park that we went to and
i swear to god there was like
like half a dozen kids on those balance
bikes and they were younger than my
daughter and they were killing it they
were flying
and i was like she needs to see this to
get motivated right so
i tell her that i'm going to take her
over there and then there's this
old-fashioned like uh
ice cream parlor that you know makes
like root beer floats and [ __ ] like that
right
like i'll take you there afterwards and
she goes awesome right so
the whole week when she was asking me
about it every day after school
going i'm gonna do the uh balance bike
and get the ice cream i'm like not today
buddy
on saturday she's like ah so finally it
was saturday
and so we went over there and of course
i get to the park and there is
nobody on a balance bike and i'm like oh
no
and we got on it and she wasn't liking
it and then a couple
kids her age a little older went by on
bicycles actually pedaling riding bikes
and she was going oh that kid's really
fast oh she's really good like she's
such a sweetheart
and um what i ended up doing
for any other dads with a young kid out
there trying the balance bike
i just turned it into a game i just say
okay i'm going to walk in front of you
so you're safe but do me a favor
don't run over daddy's toes okay don't
she immediately big grin on her face
so now she's trying to run over my toes
i'm going like whoa whoa easy easy just
making i'm just making her laugh her ass
off
and next thing you know i mean she's
gone like you know 50 yards
trying to run over my feet and then i
was
gradually increasing how much i was
backpedaling which
making her go faster and faster right
so we went around once it was like a
quarter mile loop or something like that
we went around it once and then she saw
me she was tired so we sat on a bench
park bench talked had a great time we're
laughing and watching the kids go by
on the bikes she saw somebody roller
skating and she was just saying oh that
girl's good oh he's really fat that boy
is really fast
and she's just it really made me
proud as a dad
um the way my daughter is coming up that
like
you know people who have come over have
said
like you know i'm not just saying this
you have like the happiest kids
and blah blah blah i'm like oh my god
i'm i'm breaking
this thing in my family i'm keeping a
ton of [ __ ] for my family tree though
okay as far as she's gonna learn how to
drive a stick shift
okay she's gonna learn you know
sports and all of that all of that great
stuff but like what i'm getting rid of
is the uh you know being afraid of your
parents
um afraid of your dad i should say like
that old school dad thing
and like um
and then also like rather than doing the
the hazing thing and ripping somebody
down
i remember i used to always say like i
want to have a kid some just so i can
build them up
obviously going to hold them accountable
when they're being a jerk but i just
really
want to be there for them for times like
this
and just build up their self-esteem
because there's so many [ __ ] in the
world you know that's the big thing
that's why you need a positive home base
or a circle of friends because you got
to walk out into it every day at least
you did back in the day before this
[ __ ]
you have to go out into it even you go
on like the internet you know you go on
these social media sites it's just
[ __ ] people [ __ ] all over you
um you know and i can't imagine all of
those
those steeler dynasties the 49ers
dynasty and all the cowboys dynasties
and all that the amount of
[ __ ] [ __ ] that they would have got if
social media was around then
and all the stuff that they would have
said about them and blah blah blah
it was a much uh you know
and a lot of it's the same but a little
you know what it is the fact that you
can just get absolutely eviscerated
and not even leave your house and not
even back in the day a stranger had to
at least say it to your face or kind of
yell it
from another car instead of now so
anyway
so then what i did today was we went to
a different place
and i found a sidewalk on a street that
wasn't busy because i always get so
scared oh my god whatever car jumps the
curb you just the [ __ ] like stephen
king [ __ ] that goes through your head
every time you take your kid out in
public
um i found one that had a slight grade
down
so it'd be easier to get speed so she
could possibly lift her feet up a little
bit
and balance but not too fast that she
was going to get afraid and fall down
and have a negative experience so we did
that
and she absolutely crushed it
and she started rather than like sort of
running with the bike
she started doing like two legs at a
time and lifting them up and i
i just was like i felt 100 feet tall i
was so proud of her
and you know i made a video and i sent
it to her you know
her nana or her auntie and all the
family so they could
all you know mom of course and they're
all centered oh my god you know great
job and all of that and
she's just the best and then i came home
and i played with my son you know when
he's killing it like he's gonna be
walking soon he's way ahead of it
because he's trying to keep up with his
sister and then i watched
the the the new england buccaneers tom
brady patriots
tom brady buccaneers win a super bowl
absolutely
amazing um my condolences to kansas city
fans
um you know i know
i know that feeling
i know that feeling and i gotta say
patrick mahomes i it might be
i've never seen a guy
get off the level of accurate throws
doing like a [ __ ] 360
[ __ ] pirouette and then just slinging
the ball
and he's still like people have a chance
and that last one
hit that guy off the face max now in
defense of the receiver like the
the defender's hand went right in front
of his face right before the ball got
there you know um
that was the only time i've ever seen
that look on his face when he was
sitting on the ground
and um if you're a kansas city
fan it's great that he experienced that
because uh that is a feeling you never
want to feel again
and he's gonna probably be going even
harder
next year so um i don't think
by any stretch of the means they're done
but i i would think that uh
they might try to add some sure up their
defense a little bit
um i did think it was hilarious the
redheaded dude the ginger
the center on the on the [ __ ] uh
buccaneers was riling up that guy on uh
kansas city and he pushes him and always
they
why did they oh i noticed they hear a
commotion and then they look and then
they see you respond and seeing brady
laughing
where it's just like yeah man that
happens every time you got to know not
to do that what it is this is i
i would think if i would like to i i
know i would retell you because i have
too much of a temper but if you have an
even keel if you play sports
this is what you somebody does some [ __ ]
like that to you
you got to go sicilian on them you don't
go right then you let them think about
what they did and you
10 minutes later a quarter later when
nobody's looking
then you get them
you don't go hothead irish guy
punch him and bite back immediately
because you're going to get cut
and i love that the redheaded dude hit
the dude
then he gets hit back and right as he
gets hit back he points like can you
believe he just did this
it reminded me of like uh like in hockey
when you got
guys that their eye their job is to go
out there and just stir it up and just
get people to get all pissed off and
everything so
anyway um i i can't i think this might
be my favorite championship brady ever
won just just as a forget the fact that
he's you know
he put us on the map just to see
a guy as great as him
move on from the team that you never
thought he would leave go to another
team not only make the playoffs
not only win a playoff game to tie what
joe montana did with the chiefs oddly
enough
to go on and beat
like drew brees part of
i i would say brady's generation right
he was a little bit later but pretty
much his generation
and then the next generation's best guy
right and then the next gen and now this
generation's best guy
on one playoff run all on the road now
granted they weren't like the big
sold out crowds but still unfucking
believable
so such as a sports fan that was
something that was something else to
watch
so uh in other news
my boston bruins just i swear to god
the most dangerous team down three goals
to none
they just keep [ __ ] coming they just
keep coming they went down to the flyers
they just kept coming [ __ ] own the
flyers so far
flyers got a good team too i'm not
talking [ __ ]
we beat him every [ __ ] game
um i was watching a little bit of that
fly
dude i watched so much sports today i
recorded a uh
the pelicans versus uh the memphis
grizzlies
and uh because you know you got the all
this young talent in those games
you know john morant and uh zion
williamson
and what's his face lonzo ball is
starting to find his whole his nba
footing the guy's [ __ ]
draining threes like nobody's business
and then i love that kid brooks
on uh memphis too he just [ __ ] goes
hard to the rack he just
he goes 100 every game love that guy um
and then i know that you know probably a
third of them will be lakers at some
point so i want to enjoy them on other
teams
first so i've been watching my celtics
during this west coast trip and we just
can't seem to put two wins together
um we beat the warriors then we lost to
sacramento and then i missed the
clippers game and then i watched the
suns game today
we beat the clippers lost to the suns so
uh whatever we is that a split we won
lost one lawyer so um
anyway and then i guess we lost to the
lakers at home so
we're like [ __ ] i think 13 and 10
or something like that and i feel like
we're better than that record so i'm
just
hoping um
we're uh i don't know i kind of like
what
brad stevens is doing is he's like he's
using
everybody everybody's getting a lot of
minutes and i think he's gonna you know
when the games are bigger and the seeds
are really starting to fall into place
later on
he's gonna try to uh you know just use
the starters more but he's
given the bench and everything priceless
minutes
that hopefully um i don't know man i
gotta tell you jason tatum
and jaylen brown i'm telling you are
gonna get a ring
after lebron retires because lebron is
just the [ __ ] man
and he has you know davis of i mean he's
got all these guys around him that guy
is just
you know that's funny brady winning
today
probably hurt the celtics
i think that's how competitive lebron is
he's probably like okay i got four i
want to get
five so i tie kobe then six
is jordan and then now we go brady seven
and we all know bill belichick is eight
and then the next one i believe there's
a bunch of celtics that have like seven
or eight
i'm not too good with that but i know
yogi berra had like 10
and then bill russell has 11. so
i don't know those are mind-boggling and
and that's what's
amazing about uh
brady getting seven to do it now when
there's so many [ __ ] teams
so many goddamn teams you know back then
i mean you could go on a [ __ ] run
you could go on a [ __ ] run um
like i always thought was really
interesting how back in the day a major
league baseball
um when the yankees were going through
that amazing period of
of babe ruth to lou gehrig to joe
dimaggio
to to mickey mantle which you're never
going to see that again and even though
they bought babe ruth whatever even if
they didn't have [ __ ] babe ruth lou
gehrig to joe dimaggio
to [ __ ] mickey mantle i've seen
people go
back to back you know brett favre to
aaron rodgers
i've seen stuff like that you know
peyton manning to andrew luck i mean
it's always good when you tank half the
season right
jim irsay you're cheating [ __ ] um
but uh sorry gamesmanship it's
indianapolis
gamesmanship um
i've seen that but i've never seen like
somebody maybe this is a good sports
theater uh
uh um what do they call that
sports question um [ __ ] what is the word
trivia sports trivia has anybody ever
done that
like right in a row and just continued
winning just three
of the best [ __ ] dudes ever and i
don't mean
free agent signing i don't mean that
because the lakers
had magic and then kobe was a [ __ ]
uh what was he uh
carolina whatever the [ __ ] they were
charlotte hornet
you know lebron you know he's been
around
all these other [ __ ] teams you know
what i mean um i just mean like you
drafted him
like that's what i always think is
amazing because like to do
from the 20s 30s 40s and 50s
just incredible [ __ ] run so what was
amazing me back then though was
they had so few teams that if you had
the best record like the
there was there was wasn't a bunch of
divisions it was just you're in the
american league
or you're in the national league and if
you had the best record
in the national league you won the
pennant
and the best record in the american
league won the pennant there weren't
playoffs there was no alcs nlcs division
series nothing
there was only one playoff series it was
the world series so
it was like i don't know like seven
eight teams in each
league and whoever had the best record
they both played each other
so um that's my thing how back then you
could go on like a run like when the
celtics were doing what they were doing
way back in the day let me see i'm just
going to look 1965
1965 nba
standings let's see how few teams there
were
of course it goes to nba standings now
why would that be
why would that be why won't you help me
here 1965-66
nba standings all right oh my god look
at this [ __ ]
the eastern division had four teams the
sixers the celtics the royals and the
knicks
the western division had had five teams
lakers bullets hawks
warriors and pistons so yeah you can go
on a run
[Laughter]
um so once again that's why i think it's
so amazing 32 teams
in parity you know to do that all right
i'm done
okay i'm done congratulations
to your congratulations to bert
kreicher's
tampa bay buccaneers [ __ ]
amazing [ __ ] amazing um
all right where the [ __ ] are we here
that's just hilarious i actually just
clicked on something that's notes
from an episode
dump prick joke frank holds on to seat
bigger air
then hands on dash
i ain't dead yet
so-and-so should hold the gun lower
this is animation all right let's get
into the uh
the reads for this week here uh and then
i'll tell you oh
let me tell you another story real quick
real quick whatever i'm in a good
[ __ ] mood i'm in a great [ __ ] mood
balance bike and then the super bowl um
i did my first stand-up show in like i
don't even know how long
i uh i did that run in texas and then i
did one show when i came back and then
somebody in the crowd had covid in their
car and i was just like you know what
[ __ ] this [ __ ] so i just kind of been
laying low and then i was just like the
other day it just dawned on me
even though i agreed to do this show
like two weeks ago like i don't even
think about stand-up anymore
i don't think about bits i don't think
about any of that [ __ ] i used to always
think like how do you stop doing so how
does somebody stop doing stand-up
if you've done it you felt the rush and
it's so much fun how the [ __ ] do you
stop
and i figured it out you know what you
just stopped doing it
and the longer you stop doing it the
less you think about it and then all of
a sudden
you're just like yeah you know
i don't i don't think i have any jokes
so i went down
as always to the magic castle which has
been my home away from home
my uh my surrogate comedy store out here
and
i did the parking lot and i went up and
did a half hour
and i had a [ __ ] blast i had a blast
and you know i had a bunch of new [ __ ]
and then i was trying to stumble my way
through some of the old stuff and i kind
of was shaking off the rust i was really
really happy about
how the whole thing went down and um
which is good because i do have a show
coming up
um i don't know if i'm allowed to
[ __ ]
announce it yet um
anyways there was this kid who was
playing high school hockey aj ketta i
hope i say his name right q-u-e-t-t-a
he suffered a spinal cord injury and
um the nhl is just doing an incredible
job raising money
and um you know
if i was doing if i could [ __ ] do
stand up at a bigger place
i would but um i'm gonna be doing like a
live
zoom stand-up show and all the proceeds
are gonna go we gotta just we haven't
really reached out to him yet it's what
we're gonna do in a couple of weeks
um i'm gonna raise some money and all
the proceeds are going to go
towards helping him and his family out
deal with all of the challenges ahead
and all that stuff
and just um i don't know it's a it's a
good thing to do um
i don't know just i just can't imagine
uh all the stuff that they're going
through so and
i've always believed that when anything
like this happens that the family
the only they shouldn't have to worry
about finances the only thing that they
should be worrying about is how to
you know put the pieces back together
and move forward
so um i just think it's so great you
know seeing the bruins they
hung his jersey marshawn's his favorite
player they hunt the jersey up on the
boards
and they had like his school color
hockey tape
on their sticks and uh warm up was just
so
really really cool so i can't imagine
what that kid's going through
and what his parents are going through
it's absolutely heartbreaking so
i want to do something for him so i will
have that information hopefully on
thursday
unfortunately it like with the
technology it's kind of limited
to like a thousand people it's going to
be like 10 bucks a ticket
and uh we'll send the money out to them
once we figure out how to do it i think
they have a startup whatever by the way
they do have a startup i think
let me just look it up here if you guys
want to donate if you
don't want to watch my dumbass dick
jokes uh
let's see rally behind north providence
is
aj ketter uh here they have a gofundme
page
um you can look it up you spell his name
a
j and then it's q-u-e-t-t-a
um but it's just been so great to see
the nhl what they've been doing the
bruins
cam neely and all of those guys have
just been absolutely amazing so
got that coming up and with that let's
do some reads here all right
oh look who it is ollie pop lollipop
talk about how much you love soda i
[ __ ] love soda
jesus christ if i could just fill my
bathtub up with root beer
and a giant beanbag size of vanilla ice
cream i could die a happy man what would
you guys do if i you if
if you if i [ __ ] overdosed
root beer floats and drowned in the tub
like uh whitney what a way to go out
um he died drinking what he loved
all right lollipop is a new kind of soda
uh tastes just like the sodas you grew
up with
but without the spoon full of sugar and
the artificial ingredients this is like
healthy soda
this is insane i feel like everybody's
like all these like new
companies are trying to right the wrongs
of
was it man santo monsanto whatever the
i'm sure they changed their name at this
point
uh they have delicious nostalgic flavors
like vintage cola
classic root beer i love that i'm so
[ __ ] old that even like my
soda is like is that root beer is a
vintage soda uh
flavor you know what i [ __ ] hate i
hate when i go do you have any root beer
and they go no we got rc cola
like they're in this even in the same
are you just saying that that's just
weird soda that nobody orders sorry why
do i have this much passion about this
orange squeeze
cherry vanilla now that's an old one
that's like sock hop right
and strawberry vanilla
come that was it at the hop you can stop
you can stop man [ __ ]
man hop um all right talk about your
favorite flavor and why you're loving it
i like the [ __ ] classic root beer
although i didn't mind the cherry
vanilla either you know
it's kind of fun to drink it you know
you know you don't feel as bad you know
you know
you're not drinking something that'll
take rust off a [ __ ] chain
it's comforting um 90 of americans
consume more than the usda's daily
recommended sugar intake
30 grams sweetened beverages like soda
are the leading source of added sugars
in the american diet lollipop has 90
percent less sugar than the leading soda
brands ollie pop is
much much lower in sugar than
conventional sodas with only 2.5 grams
of sugar with natural
sources and zero added sugar their
vintage cola has just two grams of sugar
as compared
to a regular cola which has three grams
of sugar
their orange squeeze has five grams of
sugar compared to the orange
fanta which has 44 grams of sugar
whoa
taking it to the moon unlike other sodas
that are full of sugar corn syrup and
artificial ingredients like ass
ass part tame aspartame lollipop
only pop jolly good is made with natural
ingredients that are actually good for
you
they are so confident you will love
their products that they will offer 100
money-back guarantee for orders placed
through the website they're basically
revolutionizing the whole
soda industry uh cta whatever that means
we've worked
out an exclusive deal for the monday
morning podcast listeners you get 20
off plus free shipping on their
best-selling variety pack plus you can
drink soda
and your wife can't give you [ __ ] about
it this is a great way to try out all
the delicious flavors
you can get the variety packs sorry free
shipping let me get back there
receive 20 off plus free shipping on
their best
selling variety pack i actually
recommend that to start
then you can start ordering the one that
you like the best or just keep getting
the variety pack
uh this is a great way to try out all of
their delicious flavors
to claim this deal go to drinkolipop.com
or use the code bur burr at checkout
that's drink lollipop
d-r-i-n-k-o-l-i-p-o-p
dot com slash bird this discount is only
valid
for their variety pack full discount
applied at check out all the lollipop
charlie good lollipop can also be found
in over 4 000 stores across the country
including
whole foods sprouts kroger and
wegmans well now that i know a little
bit about the stock market there may be
somebody good to [ __ ] invest it
people still don't quite know about them
and they're already in whole foods
i mean am i crazy be like that bald guy
screaming about stalks
all right simply safe everyone wants to
keep their home and family safe whether
it's from a break-in a fire
flooding or a medical emergency for
christ's sake get off the floor
uh simply safe home security delivers
award-winning 24 7 protection
with simply safe you don't just get an
arsenal of cameras and sensors you get
the best professional monitors in the
business
they got you back day and night ready to
send the police fire or emts when you
need them
most straight to your door
talk about your own experience with
simply safe high quality equipment great
camera if
it makes me feel good i feel like tony
montana i know what's going on in my
house
and i also know that i'm not good at
fighting so i can have somebody come
over here
and get rid of the bad guys simply safe
has an arsenal of sensors and cameras
that protect every inch of your home you
can set it up
set it up rack them yourself in about 30
minutes it's super easy then simply save
that's what i did like is you can put
them wherever the hell you want to put
them so if you have like troubled areas
you know what i mean your house is
settling you know there's certain areas
where you're just like i think i don't
know
i think a coyote could get up over that
wall right there then simply
you just put it up all right then simply
safe professionals take over monitoring
your home 24 7
and ready to send help the moment
there's an alarm plus with simply safe
there's no long-term contract no hidden
fees or installation costs call to
action right now my listeners get a free
home security system
when you purchase a simply safe system
simply safe dot com slash birth
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e-d.com you also get a
60-day risk free trial
so there's nothing to lose all right
visit simplysafe.com for your free
security camera today that's
simplysafe.com
all right oh we got a lot of reads here
policy genius
policy genius you know it's the shortest
month of the year
which we can only mean one thing we're
honoring black people
meaning meaning you've got
slightly less time to check out
your february to-do's and look at st
patrick's day right in the middle
honoring white people in a 31
full month 31 full day month luckily
policy genius can get
can help you kill two birds with one
stone compare home and auto insurance
rate
and save up to one thousand fifty five
dollars per year by reshopping
that's money you can put towards the
things you care about
uh whatever that may be here's how it
works first head to policygenius.com and
answer a few quick questions about
yourself and your property
then policy genius takes it from there
they compare rates so for from over 30
top insurers from progressive to
nationwide is on your side
to find you the lowest quotes the policy
genius team
will look at all the ways to maximize
your savings including bundle
bundling your home and auto policies if
policy genius finds a better rate than
what you're paying now
they'll they'll switch
you you over for free wow it's a major
type you know like back in the day when
they would
write a curse word but instead of
writing it they would just use like the
and sign the number sign and all of that
that's what was just in the copy anyway
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across
over 1600 reviews on trust pilot
and google if you're worried that march
is around the corner and you've barely
gotten anything done take a deep breath
policy genius will help you make the
most of your short month
in minutes just reshop your home and
auto insurance and you could
save up to one thousand fifty five
dollars head to policygenius.com
to get started right now policy genius
when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right now we're
going to end with two classics
policy genius that was like our new uh
our new cutoff
off the latest album and now we're going
to come back for the encore
all right we're going in with our living
on a prayer
oh zip
finding great candidates to hire can be
like trying to find a needle in a
haystack
sure you can post your job you sure you
can post to some job board
but then all you can do is hope for the
right person to come along
which is why you should try ziprecruiter
for free ziprecruiter.com at
ziprecruiter.com
zip did tom brady win another one
recruiter
works for you when you post your job on
zip recruiter it gets sent out to over
100 top job sites with one clip then zip
recruiter matches technology matches
matching technology finds people with
the right skills and experience for your
job
and actively invites them to apply you
get qualified candidates fast
so while other services may overwhelm
you with applications to sit through
just zip planet four net for another
eight yards
find you what you're looking for the
needle in the haystack in fact zip
recruiter is so effective
that four out of five employers who post
on zip
no touchdowns for patrick mahomes
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day
and right now you can try zip recruiter
for free at ziprecruiter.com
right well ziprecruiter.com that's it
tom brady's agreed to seven number seven
recruiter.com spell it out
c r z-i-p-r-e-c-r-u i t e r dot com
oh look who it is stamps.com stamps.com
is [ __ ] here
all right the old friends here look who
it is stamps.com let's face it
taking trips to the post office is
probably not how you want to spend your
time especially with covid you could
kill all those old people standing in
line trying to send out their brownies
to their grandkids
uh that's why i recommend mailing and
shopping online at stamps.com stamps.com
allows you
to ship at any time anywhere right from
your computer send letters ship packages
and pay a lot less with discounted rates
from ups
and you the usps united states postal
service and more
yeah and it's it's a great way during
covet to do this you know stamps.com has
saved
businesses thousands of hours and tons
of money with stamps.com you get the
services of the post office and ups
all in one place plus big discounts on
mailing and shipping rates
you've heard me talk about stamps.com
they've been sponsoring
the show for over nine years now and you
know what has happened over the last
nine years tom brady got four more rings
wow and if you haven't tried it what are
you waiting for stamps.coms brings the
services of the u.s postal service and
ups right to your computer
stamps.coms is a is a must-have
for any business whether you're a small
office sending out invoices and online
sellers shipping out orders
or even a giant warehouse sending
thousands of packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with these
and simply use your computer to print us
postage 247
for any letter any package any class of
mail anywhere you want to send once your
mail is ready
just schedule a pick up or drop it off
it's that simple with stamps.com
you get discounts of up to 40 off post
office rates and just
and up to 62 percent off ups
shipping rates not to mention stamps.com
is a fraction of the cost of those
expensive post-its meters
stamps.com is a no-brainer saving you
time and money it's no wonder nearly 1
million small businesses already use
stamps.com
stop wasting time going to the post
office and go to stamps.com instead
there's no risk
and with my promo code burr you get the
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus free this is like over
selling we got it it's [ __ ] amazing
you get a [ __ ]
special offer that includes four week
trial plus free post it's a little
digital scale no long-term contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone the top of the homepage and
type in burr burr stamps.com
promo codebar burr stamps.com never go
to the post office again
all right all right now it's on to you
guys well it's about time
i just feel like doing 45 minutes about
how much you love tom brady it's a
little tone jeff
during the pan demi
um anyway okay here we go
iran coming in from iran coming in hot
all right hey bill my name is amir
abbas ali mohammed dude you have to get
into show business you have to be a
boxer or something
fighting under the blue corner he's the
current middleweight champion and i ran
his name in hamir
no muhammad you got an i at the end of
it all right yes that's a long name hey
dude
kareem abdul-jabbar was one of my
favorite sports names of all time
yes that's a long name i'm an 18 year
old iranian i live in tehran and i'm a
game designer so you're crushing it you
basically live in the manhattan
of uh you live in the new york city of
iran
you design games well i want to know
what kind of games do you design are
they the same
same ones we do over here like what is
your version of grand theft auto look
like i want to i want to see that
uh and i want to work in big game
development studios in the future
i know they probably have you guys all
sewed up over there too right
can you break off and start your own
[ __ ] um
so you actually get the credit anyway i
love western countries and especially
america i love american
american musicians like elvis or frank
sinatra
look at that he's going old school here
uh so what do you think of iran
you know life is kind of hard here but
hey i don't blame america for it
it's mostly our government's fault when
you see
in the media about the people is mostly
wrong but everything you hear about my
government
you have to multiply by 10 to understand
how evil they are
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute
is this real dude if your government's
that evil why the [ __ ] did you
have me say you i'm gonna bleep out your
[ __ ] name unless this is just some
redneck
writing and pretending to be an iranian
i have no idea
um anyway i don't want to get you in
trouble
um where am i
uh what you hear you've seen it it's ten
times
evil okay i watch your stand-ups and i
really loved them
i liked louis c.k too and of course
you were amazing in the mandalorian by
the way you were way
better than all of the okay okay okay
let's
take it down a little uh so what what do
you think of iran
if you have any passport other than
american passport
you can visit our country sorry for my
english um
when i think about it unfortunately i'll
probably never go there because
of the relationship that uh you know you
and i could hang out
you know we wouldn't have a problem talk
video games and comedy and [ __ ]
movies and [ __ ] but like for some reason
the
[ __ ] at the top can't seem to settle
their differences
without having to have people from uh
you know friends you know
friends i know go over there you know
over here whatever you try to kill each
other it's [ __ ] i don't
i don't get why war is still legal i
don't understand it
you know i can't do a caitlyn jenner
joke but like we can [ __ ]
go around bombing countries or they can
bomb us i just don't understand it
um
yeah it's just all that [ __ ] paranoia
it's really i don't know i guess you
have to have a healthy thing what do i
think about
um i'll be honest with you i'm worried
for you guys i'm worried for a guy like
you
all right if you're a real person if
this isn't just somebody [ __ ] with me
like just regular people over there i
would hate to be in your situation
where you know you're sitting on top of
a bunch of stuff that another
nation wants um you know
like i said i really wish joe biden
would just take a ride in a tesla and we
would sort of just at some point
walk away from these [ __ ] oil
companies or just
let them in on the whole solar thing so
they can transition over
because they're killing all of us the
banks and oil companies are just
killing all of us they're just [ __ ]
just greedy [ __ ] i mean it's not just
them there's other people and i'm also a
selfish cut
i just don't run an oil company so i
don't know i don't i don't have any what
do i think about you guys
i hope you're safe i hope we don't go to
war with each other i hope all your
dreams come true i hope you're able to
design games and
find love and have some kids and just
have live a full life
that's what i want for everybody unless
you're a [ __ ] if you're a [ __ ] i hope
you walk into the sea and help
feed the fish all right i ran okay trump
vs biden
uh bill you're listening to the [ __ ]
on this
trump tore up our nuclear treaty with
iran in the beginning of his term
trump thought it was too soft on iran
trump dropped a bomb
on one of iran's top generals
trump treated all kinds of war on iran
during his whole term buying is trying
to renegotiate the old treaty
no biggie yeah treaty negotiations talk
big talk but compared to what we had the
last four years
go [ __ ] yourself well uh those were four
sentences i'll give you that but i i
don't you know
listen dude if you saw how many bombs
[ __ ] obama dropped i don't know how
to tell you this dude
they're all working for the same guy the
same guys and i will say the one thing
about trump was
they nobody knew what the [ __ ] he was
going to do that's why he had to go not
because progressives were sick of them
i think because nobody could make any
[ __ ] money because you got to know
what the guy's going to do
that guy had zero tendencies you could
be the biggest [ __ ] trump fan
in the world and all you knew was that
he wasn't gonna do what people were
suggesting to do
that's all you knew um he is a
contrarian's contrarian
um but i also don't pay attention that
much to politics i don't give a [ __ ]
okay i like people i don't think we
should drop bombs to settle our [ __ ]
differences
and i don't think that makes me a
[ __ ] hippie either
um it's [ __ ] bananas man but whatever
that's how we do it
it's how we've always done it and that's
how we're gonna continue doing it
so what are you gonna do
um
sorry okay screaming so much during the
game my throat's getting a little
scratchy here oh jeez it's getting all
scratchy all right
another one from iran dear billy
barracks uh you're right about iran oh
no i'm right
people i don't know [ __ ] about iran um
the us will be leading the charge and
removing leadership it won't be as
bloody as iraq but we're going
to [ __ ] [ __ ] up i work in the government
and i can tell you that the amount of
chatter has gone up a bit in the last
year or two
according to an older colleague of mine
this is how
it went with iraq well they're using the
same [ __ ] story
even if 911 hadn't happened we could
have gone into iraq with the propaganda
machine
that was barreling down the tracks some
people think 911 just pushed up the
schedule to go to iraq
which makes sense if since it had
nothing to do with 911
and it seemed like some people really
wanted to get in there
trump is a tough guy so he needed the
nuclear treaty with iran
cause because he thought it was too soft
but he thought but but he could only
really do that
because the military-industrial oh god
this word military industrial complex
let him now is the military-industrial
complex that is
the corporations that sort of dictate
where
the military goes the industrial being
corporations industry
i think that was one of the biggest
blunders in american history
was that uh eisenhower called it the
military industrial complex
to the point that the lay person dummy
like me has no idea what he's talking
about anyway
um he should have been like he's [ __ ]
oil company he's gonna start determining
where we go
uh i think they did so uh they could
blame him for
when we go to war under biden
um well i mean then you're kind of
assuming that everybody is liberal
that is involved in that um i just don't
think it matters
like i think if one of those other
republicans won
the nomination and beat hillary
which was easy just because she was a
terrible public speaker terrible public
speaker
and it's show business you got to get up
there and you know [ __ ]
[Music]
twirl the baton right um
i think that we probably would have gone
in i just think that that's just how it
works
if you want to get the mansion on
martha's vineyard you got to do what
they say
anyways biden's cabinet is full of bush
obama-era war mongers
they'll be the ones who actually go to
war all right well
i don't pay attention to this [ __ ] but
that a lot of that stuff made sense to
me you don't have to agree with it so
people please don't
email me in capital letters it's just a
podcast
all right let's try to stay focused here
uh stimulus
um that's a great name for like a
a greek porn star steve
stimulus you know sort of sounds greek
and he's also going to be stimulating
him with his giant greek [ __ ] porno
[ __ ]
no all right hey bill my delusional
family
coworker and friends all told me that
when biden won we get the stimulus check
we deserved
i made some of them say it on video
because i knew
they'd twist their words oh that's great
you got him to say it on video they were
all wrong and i've been gloating the
news barely covers it
and there are less demands from twitter
activists
anyways no stimulus even with the dems
in charge
i think you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] if you
believe that only the republicans are
evil
i actually always argued that democrats
were worse because at least the
republicans
don't pretend like they give a [ __ ]
about me
you know they're like [ __ ] you [ __ ]
pull yourself up by your own bootstraps
i got money and you can watch me spend
it for all i give a [ __ ] you can starve
right on my front yard i don't give a
[ __ ]
and the democrats like we love you we
love you and then they didn't drop bombs
and buy mansions and [ __ ] martha's
vengeance they're all the same [ __ ]
[ __ ]
all right my dad's anger gave him
parkinson's oh you [ __ ] well
some people's anger gives them a heart
attack
who's oh god is this oh ladies and
gentlemen it's time for
the adventures of internet doctor
my favorite show on tv internet doctor
he never went he and she never went to
medical school they just went on a
website and they read some stuff
okay hi bill i just saw another clip of
you raging
on people's now overly sensitive
attitudes a menial job worker
sucking at their menial job and your dad
being someone you were scared of
uh it's like we lived the same youth
part of it is definitely the old man
who's the angriest person i ever met i
am 38 years old
with two little girls and my wife is
constantly telling me to calm down
after i overreact at my kids moving
their chairs without lifting them i
don't yell at my kids but i i yell at
stuff
tvs phones uh
toasters uh just dragging the thing
across the floor
guaranteeing a knock on the door from
our downstairs neighbor i hold in my
fury until the neighbor leaves
then lose it at my kids ah dude you
can't yell at your kids
he goes it sucks but they should lift
their [ __ ] chairs
yeah but dude your kids shouldn't pay
for your childhood
you got to work on that man and i'm i'm
i'm saying this to you and to me because
i
i i don't want this uh that's why i was
so thrilled when people said you have
like happy kids
um he says anyway my dad was diagnosed
with parkinson
and i [ __ ] you not the doctor said he
wouldn't be surprised if my dad had
anger issues
like if you spend your life angry you
end up with parkinson's as the ultimate
karmic
payback yeah i don't buy that it scared
the [ __ ] out of me and i was hoping you
could make some jokes
about it to lighten the mood all all the
best yeah i mean
i mean that's just a theory and also if
you really look at why so many people
are angry it's because they were hurt as
kids
and i don't think when you're a
defenseless kid that if somebody
was evil to you mean to you or
frightened you
that you should pay the car shouldn't
the person that yelled at you
i guess if you're yelling at your kids
but i'm not yelling at my kids i don't
yell at my kids
so i don't know dude i i think it
probably comes
comes down to you know i think it's a
little
more beyond that but i i also
i kind of believe that like i do think
if you're an abusive
in your in a verbally abusive
relationship
for years and years and years that that
that does some sort of
however you hold on to it i think it's
probably unique you know some people
might
get like uh i don't know physical aims
other people might get a [ __ ] disease
i have no idea how it works
i'm not a doctor but i i've i had to
guess
in years to come they're going to sort
of map out some [ __ ]
of how a disease cannot be necessarily
in your family tree but but some
[ __ ] you went through
um they'll probably and then realize
that meditation
is the way to cure a lot of stuff at
which point
the pharmaceutical companies will
suppress that information
and then come up with drugs and try to
do things to keep you angry so they can
keep making money
that's what i would guess all right
girlfriend will leave me if i don't get
a normal job
okay hey billy ball bag uh
i love your show and i know
you don't like compliments so i'll just
cut to the chase thank you
i'm an 18 year old redheaded dude just
like yourself
i've been dating my girlfriend for the
last two months two and a half years
sorry
it's been going great we very much enjoy
each other's company and have some
of the same interests but here is the
problem i'm trying to become a comedian
i don't want to get on stage is i want
to get on stage as soon as i can
to make a career out of it that means i
don't want to go to college and get a
desk job
i've told my girlfriend that i i will
still work my ass off to help pay the
bills
when we eventually move in together dude
these are some deep conversations for
18.
she doesn't see comedy as a good job for
her spouse to have
i've told her i'm already trying to get
my name out there by starting a podcast
but she sees it as a temporary thing
she's threatened to leave me if i don't
go to college and get a degree in some
[ __ ] that i don't want to do
uh i don't know what to say to her i
love her so much but i don't want to
give up my dream
any advice is helpful thanks and go [ __ ]
yourself
yeah dude you need to dump her
if she doesn't come around this is what
you don't need a dumper you just say say
listen i'm doing this this is my dream
and i want to be with somebody that is
going to support my dream
i'm going to support your dreams okay
but your dream can't be that my dream
doesn't come true
okay that's like the genie wishes you
can't wish for more wishes right
it's like if your dreams to become a
nurse i will support you doing that
first of all dude this is way too
serious a [ __ ] relationship to be in
at 18 years of age
what is it the 1700s you're gonna die
when you're 30
um this is what you do you want to
[ __ ] make it as a comic
you [ __ ] go be a comedian and you
don't let anybody tell you you can't
[ __ ] do it
and you don't you know you learn from
people you keep your ears open you be
uh you know nice to people and
everything but the second you get
somebody coming at you
trying to take you know trying to take
that light out of you
you just shut it down dude you shut it
down and this is a great
[ __ ] experience for you to have at
this age because i didn't figure this
[ __ ] out till i was about 10 years older
than you
and now i literally i don't have anybody
in my life like that
now and like if i
even sense that around me like i almost
break out in hives i just get like i
don't
i don't like literally walk away from
him but i just go in my head
i just go i am i this this is just
bounce it just bounces off me
i'm not listening to any of this [ __ ]
and uh yeah if you try to sell me on
fear
i'm not listening to you sell me on
logic
okay as long as what i'm doing is
rational
like if my dream was to become the best
hitman the cia has ever had
then like you know i can see you trying
to talk hey you know you're gonna have
to [ __ ] bet you when you get older
even if it was good for the country
you might see that a few of them maybe
you know you probably should you know
you know you're just gonna go tell jokes
so
if you really love her and everything
and she really loves you you'll be able
to work it out but i'll just say i would
just say this there just say listen
this is my dream and i'm going to do
this
and if this is going to work i need you
to support me you got to support my
dream
i'm not asking you to to work all day
why i don't have a job
and um and this is the thing dude if she
walks away
right who gives a [ __ ] then she wasn't
the one for you
you're only 18 years of age and dude you
could become a [ __ ] comedian you
could start selling tickets
i mean dude i went to summer school like
[ __ ] i should have gone every year
but i had a cool teacher my sophomore
year and
senior year what was the point i said
[ __ ] it
and i still made okay
and i'm making way better a living than
i would have
if i did some of the other jobs i
thought of doing
so i mean you're going i mean anytime
you're going after your dream i mean
that's just like that's
no one should ever take that from you
dude don't let anybody ever do that okay
and that's a really um she's only if
she's your age i mean whatever i mean
you guys are still kids so she doesn't
know any better
and i don't know what but um
i got to be honest i can forgive that at
but like there's only like i don't know
if somebody's still saying that [ __ ] by
24 if you're saying that male or female
you're a [ __ ]
and you mean you need to be shown the
door
all right but you guys are just kidding
so dude you go do your [ __ ] stand up
and you don't let anybody stop you
all right and you know it's gonna be
an amazing amazing journey i had such an
amazing time and there's a bunch of
[ __ ]
hills you got to climb and all this
stuff then that's gives you all your
stories that builds your character
and all of that but i'll tell you
climbing those hills the last [ __ ]
thing you need is someone hanging onto
your leg trying to drag you back down it
so have your conversation
all right and if she breaks up with you
go watch the bronx tale and you know
that everybody gets three great women
all right so you still got two more
coming and you just make sure
the next one while the one after that
supports your dream or they can all hit
the [ __ ] bricks
that's what i say all right
congratulations to tom brady and the
tampa bay buccaneers
condolences to kansas city chiefs fans
um
hell of a season sucks that somebody has
to [ __ ] lose the super bowl but you
guys are uh
you know there's no reason why you won't
be there again next year and i'm telling
you that [ __ ] look on patrick mahomes
face on that last one you know when he
was sitting there
i'm telling that's gonna pay dividends
for chiefs fans in the future i really
believe that all right that's it go pats
go bruins go red sox go celtics i don't
give a [ __ ] if they're still playing or
not um
all right i'll talk to you guys i'll
check in on you on thursday you